i told you over the last many months
about some of the hidden costs of covid
the spike in suicides drug overdoses
domestic abuse
but there's another one hidden beneath
the surface child
sex trafficking now tim ballard founder
of operation underground railroad says
that it's
risen to a level he's never seen
all due to these draconian lockdowns and
increased protests
and now it includes one of the worst
criminal gangs in the world
nearly a dozen ms-13 gang members were
just arrested in virginia
for trafficking and brutally beating a
13-year-old girl
the man prosecuting the case zachary
terwilliger u.s attorney for the eastern
district of virginia
made clear that their operations need
leaders in office
who will not shy away from targeting
this illegal activity
combating ms-13 is not anti-immigrant
it's pro-immigrant we're
going after the people who are preying
upon our immigrant communities law
enforcement is key
to this operation but you know who's
also key to this is our elected leaders
in calling out uh what's actually going
on
joining me now is u.s attorney
terwilliger himself
mr twiliger why did you find
that particular message so important
thanks a lot laura it's key if we're
going to actually attack this problem
we've got to identify it
and it needs to be a whole of government
approach so much
about ms-13 gets politicized and folks
will say it's anti-immigrant as as we
just discussed and as you just showed
it's key that ms-13 preys upon the
immigrant community it sex
trafficks their daughters and it
brutally attacks their sons and extorts
individuals hard-working immigrants in
this country by threatening the violence
here
in el salvador and for so many if you
seek to enforce
any type of rule law against this gang
it's seen as being anti-immigrant that's
simply not the case
now here's how biden has been discussing
illegal immigration watch
there will not be another foot of wall
constructed
in my administration 11 million
undocumented aliens are already
americans in my view
would a biden presidency hurt efforts
combating ms-13
if the border is going to be treated in
the way it seems like it'll be treated
by
like by biden like an inconvenience
something that should be kind of
monitored but
certainly not the way the trump
administration has
from when i from where i'm sitting laura
and i'll leave for others to determine
what a biden presidency is going to look
like is what i can tell you prove
positive
is when we have a gang like ms-13 and we
attack them
click by click and we dismantle them
when we have a porous border
individuals flooding across that border
in 2019 i think the high water mark was
144 000 encounters in a month
now we're down in april to 16 000.
we can actually gain a foothold we can
get ahead but when
individuals who want to come here and do
harm
and join gangs like ms-13 or already
gang members flood across the borders
it's simply a game of whack-a-mole and
we can't win
because there's been cases in the
eastern district of virginia
where we've had individuals gang members
who've been deported
and they're back in the washington dc
area
in three to four weeks after the
deportation that just doesn't work
well people also have to know that this
is
big money i just like the drug trade is
big money
trafficking these young immigrant girls
from countries in central america that
is
big business what we figured out is just
awful is drugs can be sold once
a human being can be sold over and over
again and a gang like ms-13 and others
are extremely well situated to recruit
these young girls
intimidate them into silence brutally
beat them into submission and rape them
and then turn them out into a population
that's equally
afraid of ms-13 to say anything about
what's going on in their own communities
it's a tremendous amount of money it's a
resource that
these gangs just exploit over and over
again and it carries
very little risk compared to drug
trafficking great to see you zach thanks
so much for your service to this country
and for this important update a lot of
people don't want to talk about this
it's very very important thanks so much
great to be with you again thank you
very much